it's not the coding itself it's the way
create
i think a business around it and serve
people
and give them a better service
[Music]
how are you i'm great good to see you so
where are you calling from right now
from tel aviv i best in israel but
you know we are working from home so
probably you'll find me in my living
room
i love it i love it so i think that
working from home the true answer is i'm
everywhere because now
there is no there is no sense in a
specific point in time
vicky i would i can't wait to hear your
story right before we started this we
were chatting a little bit about the
both
you know the idea of mentorship but also
the idea of of the responsibilities of
being an entrepreneur for a good impact
following this idea of bootstrapping a
company and i'd love to spend these 20
minutes touching on these three subjects
because i think they're fascinating and
i'd love to start with with the middle
one
about what it means to be an
entrepreneur to you
and the privilege of being an
entrepreneur in terms of the
responsibility that we that we can
undertake
onto ourselves okay it's a good question
i think it's always take ownership
okay no matter if you are the expert of
a subject or a topic
you must take ownership because it's
yours
and if stuff cracks between if
something goes wrong you need to step in
and you can stay
okay it's not mine right so i think the
main
characteristic and a second
not to miss a good opportunity if you
see one
but you must say no for almost
everything else
so that's counterintuitive because when
you think of entrepreneurship a lot of
the times you think of yes
yeah a yes person right yes and yes and
but you're saying that most of the time
your responsibility is to say no
yes because you need to stay focused and
you need to invest yourself
it's not 100 it's really 200 percent
because you must take yourself out of
the box you must be more creative than
you expected
you must encounter in many difficulties
and many stuff that will tell you no
don't do it why why
why do i need it right and you must
continue
so you're so you're an entrepreneur
yourself a multiple time entrepreneur
you're also deep into the technology
scene and helping companies
with create better technology through
through your
most recent now global consulting firm
that helps them that helps them
write software that skills talk to me a
little bit about what this business does
and
and then i'd love to go back all the way
to the journey of how you started it how
you bootstrapped it
and and move from there
what we do with products and and if you
pronounce it correct it's a
production and operations okay you can
combine both of them we help clients to
build and deploy
solutions to automate their cloud
infrastructure
and improve the whole workflow of how
you deliver
code it's great that you have code right
but until it won't live
in real world and people won't be able
to use it
it's worth nothing it's a backlog
okay so so what do you actually how do
you actually go in and and help these
companies because you know
sometimes companies that have like a
dozen engineers they have a lot of
different systems they have a lot of
internal conventions and it sounds a
little complicated for an external
external group to come in and help them
understand what they have and deploy it
we start from a process what do you want
to achieve okay
now and what is the business uh let's
call it impact that you would like to
create
you want to deliver a feature that we
will create the wow moment
okay let's focus on your user
okay and once you focus on your user we
explain the flow back
what you have in your functionality of
your systems
today that it's good enough and you can
improve it
and then let's find ways to improve it
if it buy
a faster delivery it's easy
by by creating better feedback loops
okay to create feedback you monitor
stuff and you can fix
better is it by scale to
other regions or countries and it's by
use cloud better and have the
opportunity to scale your systems
and provide your service in different
countries in the same time
so we look on the business outcomes that
our customers need
we see what are the battle necks that
they have in the process
and we can only after we achieved it
we think that we can consult on what do
you want what practices do you want to
about lean development
is it good for you agent development
okay we are not agile um
mentors but we understand what does it
mean
so you're not just on the deployment
right you're actually what you're
talking about here is the whole pipeline
of a company that comes in and says
we're so where we have software
that is helping us create a service for
people
and you can actually interject in any
part of the pipeline right not just the
deployment
to the cloud or to the user exactly
we are we don't have any let's call it
added advantage
in what you develop but how
you bring it to your customers how you
deploy it to your customers what is the
process to do it
in a better way so why why do you need
products
why does the world or why do teams
around the world need an external
company to come in and help them achieve
that goal
and because it sounds like to know you
know today you know you have devops
internally you have different you know
scrum masters internally
why why would i want a an external firm
to come in and help me
okay because you find yourself a dealing
with a lot of backlog around you
you can always probably say okay i have
a lot of
work how do i start how can i create a
different
because i need to do the maintenance i
need to do the work
okay i can't you step back
and look at it from another engine
and i need someone external that will
help me to do it okay
second to overcome and technical
challenges it takes a lot
of time okay it's not that you can call
yourself okay you are a java developer
great so you will know new stuff that
happens with java for example
but it's not java you have in cloud
native landscape a lot of tools
and each one of them can uh let's call
it take you a step forward
what tool do you need to use now how can
you use a tool that won't add complexity
more than it needs so so what it sounds
to me is that you're not
what it sounds is that this the firm
doesn't go in and you're not
completing jira tasks right for the team
you're not actually going in and
necessarily helping them code the
product but you're helping them
understand
at a higher level how do the different
products within the company serve the
customer
how do you make sure that the team the
teams work efficiently and how do you
take a step back and understand
what are the priorities that the startup
or the enterprise
needs to accomplish in order to maximize
on their value for their customer
exactly and from time to time we also
step
into the hands-on work itself and if we
need to help our clients
to scale up his big technical
capabilities
in the delivery pipeline in the cloud
infrastructure
systems we do it as well okay and so how
many people
are are part of this group products
uh we have 20 people
almost 20 people in israel london
and miami for those three countries why
miami
why miami yes it's a good question one
of her
okay if you want good relationship with
their wife or your
employee she need to have a career and
she
one of our
senior directors and wanted to move
to the us and his wife is a doctor
and she accepted it to a miami beach
hospital okay
so it's not a bad reason it's not such a
good you know
uh decision but we live with it so it's
okay i love it
well you know in in kobe times anybody
can work anywhere and i guess the only
issue is the time difference
but i guess as an entrepreneur you're
already very adapted to working across
time time zones and and being awake at
all sorts of weird hours
now i i'd love for you to take me back
to your journey and before we started
this you mentioned
this this idea of bootstrapping and and
saying no
and saying no specifically to
institutional funding because you know
here in
here in palo alto all that i'm hearing
all day is when are you going to raise
your next round and how quickly can you
raise the round and how much money can
you raise
and it sounds to me like you have a
story that
doesn't go along with that narrative
specifically right
it's only when you need the money and
for the growth
okay and you can do it by yourself uh
what i think we proved to ourselves that
we
managed to create value from almost the
first day
okay of our work and
and we managed i think to do bootstrap
for let's call it for initiatives that
we decided to do
but we take small risks there is a price
to it okay we take small
risk we probably won't be able to take
bigger bigger
and but it's good enough for us or now
so how do you manage that balance as an
entrepreneur between
taking the money being able to go in and
go do high risk things versus
bootstrapping maintaining ownership and
control of the company
and in the decision-making process but
not being able to take those big risks
i will take them when i will i think
will know that it's not eventually
that it's really the green light for me
that i will be able to scale
because i have the money okay not
because
because the business needed not a good
enough reason
okay because i will uh let's call it
uh have more clients and i will need
more people to sell them
right it's also not a good reason
because if i can sell them and i can get
money why do i need external money
right but but but what is the downside
of getting
of getting a an institutional investment
and saying okay now i want to grow my
team at
i want to grow my team at products from
20 people to 200 people
and instead of serving a few clients i
want to serve hundreds of clients
because
it sounds to me like you're convinced
that you've reached product market fit
and you're providing value
to these companies and you're learning a
lot from the process then why not take
that leap
because i think that our uh let's call
it mid
uh management team is not ready for it
right now
and he'll be ready i think i'll do it
so what you're saying here is that
there's a dilemma for an entrepreneur
where
you also need to take account are we
ready to be able to manage a company at
a greater scale than what we have are we
are we ready both in terms of our
product but also in terms of our
management
yes internally of course and then so
then what what's your role
in higher yeah of course i can go in
higher but it's not the way
we believe we can we can do a great um
let's call it skill for ourselves so
then
so you know one of the things that
institutional investors help with is
keeping the entrepreneur accountable
and keeping a reality check constantly
because they're not
you know necessarily emotionally
invested into the idea but they're
looking at the product and the value
that it provides so how do you then
as an entrepreneur and the ceo how do
you keep that reality check for yourself
without the without the help of the of
the vc
uh i have a good advisory board and i
have a good mentor
i think it's always a good
tip for anyone you need to have an
external
mentor and you're ready to be able to
look at his eyes and say please give me
the truth
all the time and check me so so that so
i'd love to transition this to the other
part that we talked about before which
is
which is mentorship and relationships as
you go along this entrepreneurial
journey
as one of the key milestones or key or
cornerstones
of an entrepreneur so talk to me a
little bit about the importance of
relationship
and mentorship in your eyes
i think a good mentor should always
ask you the question is is it still your
goal
and if it's your goal let's make sure
that every decision that you make
meets your goal okay i think
it's one of the main characters of a
good mentor
okay second if in his eyes
you're not in the best position for your
company
you're not doing not doing the good job
he need to tell you
you need to move think about it consider
to make a transition
consider how would you like to grow
from this now from this point
and it's the way i look at a good mentor
and those are the questions that i keep
asking my mentor
all the time on every meeting that i
think we have about a strategic topic
that we would like to discuss
right but we obviously can't take for
granted this idea of finding a good
mentor so how do
how do you go about even finding that
right person to help you on your journey
because you know it's it's wonderful to
have that person but but it sounds
pretty difficult to find somebody who's
committed to helping you as an
entrepreneur and giving you that real
honest and direct advice because that
takes time and effort
it takes time and effort you need to try
to gain a trust
person okay again trust i think it's the
main difficulty and believes that
he has added value for you and
i met my one of my great mentors
uh in a different world let's call it uh
from theory of constraints
world if you're familiar with the
practice i'm not what is that
okay professor leon godras wrote a book
the goal maybe you're familiar with the
name the goal
i'm i'm not familiar now wow
okay i have homework after this no but
yes
management practice company like apple
and amazon work by this practice and
it's why they're
such great companies because they find
a let's call it a
weakness in the whole chain of a process
okay and they improve only the one
bottleneck that is the weakest
let's call it i even
they don't agree let's call it in this
way
they find the bottleneck once they find
the bottleneck they fix it
and then they ask you okay is my process
improved or not
right that i want in my life so it's
because he always keep looking for
the weakest things that i have in my
business
right when he point on it i work very
hard to improve it
so just to make sure that i understand
this whole concept is that you're
looking at your whole
supply chain whether it's your life your
business or a product and you're saying
out of the 100 things that i'm doing
maybe 20 of them are bad but what is the
worst one that is really stopping my
company right now from growing
the weakest link let's capitalize on
that solve that and then re
re-measure what is our new landscape who
what is our like now a hundred of
different elements
now maybe 19 of them are just bad but
but what is the next weakest link
and slowly take those out of the
equation right
yes it's a logical process and you need
to deep dive
into it and you need to ask yourself
five why's
and not one or two and make sure that
it's exactly what you do and not fixing
symptoms
right why are you so excited about the
work that you're doing
why why products why helping teams with
software before we were talking about
impact and the responsibility of an
entrepreneur for a better world so why
specifically the industry that you're in
where you're helping
companies bring their idea to impact and
fruition
and obviously could have gone to a lot
of different other paths
why did you choose this one i think
because
we help much more ideas
in the real world really it's what does
it mean go to production
we know from our previous experience 80
from your software goes to garbage right
right
because each one see that they they like
even and we help our customers ready to
deliver their code to production
right is what makes our item exciting
it's not the
coding itself it's the way create
i think a business around it and serve
people
and give them a better service i love it
okay vicky now
the hardest question which i did not
give you enough time to to prepare for
i need three words that you would use to
describe yourself or any of your clients
would use to describe yourself
who is vicky slavin okay
someone trustful okay
why trustful i think yes people can
trust me
and i think i earned it
for 20 of the time in a business and
different businesses that i did
i think second
i have high intuition and
okay and i make decisions by it
and
i think and then i thought things that
you didn't give me time to think about
it
i take ownership oh on things
and that's how we started the
conversation and that's how we're ending
it i i mean i that that's inspiring for
me to hear i completely agree i mean
then
taking ownership and and responsibility
i think is the number one key no matter
it's not just entrepreneurship it's
anything that you do
i think it's the also the essence of
being a trusted person right
having other people know that you take
ownership over your actions and over
your words
i think that's really inspiring vicky
one piece of advice that you would give
to a rising
entrepreneur that is just on their path
as they go along their journey now
i think it's create positive
environments
where people work learn or spend their
time create good environment for for
people
because if not what are the words
right so i think they need to create a
good culture
in every company that they start and
establish and the way they grow
supposed to be and
create good environment for real people
right not good conditions
okay not good i think opportunities
or good money just good environment
i love it vicky thank you very very much
today
and best of luck with products thank you
very much have a lovely day
take care bye
you